Transcription: Hélène VERNET
Relecteur: eric vautier
Voici l’histoire d’un être
étonnant nommé « Joie ».
Dans sa plus tendre enfance,
Joie rêve beaucoup, de jour comme de nuit.
Elle rêve de devenir grande.
Elle se voit avec une majuscule
à chaque lettre de son prénom.
Mais voilà, c’est étrange,
Joie est née grande !
Et les années passent,
et Joie pense raisonnablement
qu’elle ne pourra jamais
grandir puisqu’elle est déjà grande.
Et chaque jour un peu plus,
Joie renonce à son rêve,
pensant qu’il ne peut se réaliser.
Chemin faisant, comme une vieillesse
qui s’installe petit à petit,
Joie commence à rapetisser.
Elle fait la rencontre de Tristesse,
un être très bavard,
et par sympathie, elle se laisse gagner
par les humeurs maussades de Tristesse,
et par ses larmes aussi.
Et puis, c’est Frustration
qui vient à sa rencontre.
En réalité, Joie rêve toujours,
silencieusement,
mais elle a fini
par avoir peur de son rêve.
Il faut dire qu’au gré
de ses fréquentations,
elle est devenue si petite
que son rêve, si accessible au départ,
est devenu très impressionnant.
Et puis, sa spontanéité la quitte,
et il ne lui reste plus,
pour tout guide, que la raison,
la raison qui lui apporte, chaque jour,
des pensées en pagaille,
du bruit dans sa tête,
une fatigue lancinante,
au point que Joie ne parviens même plus
à faire les petites choses qu’elle aime.
Et, devenue comme une ombre,
elle fait la rencontre de la Mort,
la Mort qui lui demande
de faire un choix :
mourir ou raviver la petite flamme.
Par chance, son rêve est resté là,
tout près, silencieux et impassible
comme un ange qui attend
le bon moment pour se manifester.
Joie l’a tout simplement
ignoré trop longtemps.
Il s’approche d’elle avec douceur
et délicatesse, et elle le voit.
Ah ! Elle lui saute au cou
et d’un coup, il s’envole.
Et il vole pendant un long moment,
à travers les nuages, sous les nuages,
au-dessus des nuages.
C’est beau, cette légèreté,
mais qu’est-ce que c’est impressionnant !
Il y a plein d’inconnu,
plein d’incertitudes.
Mais comme par enchantement,
leurs péripéties se terminent toujours
par des sourires et des éclats de rire.
Joie comprend alors
que pour que son rêve se réalise,
il faut qu’elle y croie.
Elle le remercie pour ce qu’elle
vient de comprendre.
Et elle lui fait la promesse de toujours
lui accorder sa confiance.
Elle lui ouvre les bras à nouveau.
Elle le serre fort contre elle,
et d’un coup, ils ne deviennent qu’un.
Et c’est ainsi que Joie
transforma son rêve en réalité.
Elle grandit, elle grandit, elle grandit,
et elle grandit encore.
Moralité, rien n’est inaccessible
à celui qui s’accroche à son rêve.
Voici une bien jolie et inspirante
histoire, n’est-ce pas ?
Alors, j’aimerais, à présent,
vous poser une ou deux questions.
Qui parmi vous connaît de ces personnes
qui rayonnent comme des soleils
même lorsque leur vie est difficile ?
Vous voulez bien lever la main,
s’il vous plaît ?
Hmm, hmm !
À présent, j’aimerais savoir
qui parmi vous aime rire.
Ah ah ! Bien sûr, le rire rend joyeux.
Rire chaque jour est vital.
Le rire est un parfait déstressant.
C’est un booster d’immunité.
Alors, c’est plus
facile à dire qu’à faire,
quand on n’a qu’une envie,
c’est tordre le cou à la vie
pour ses injustices,
ses inégalités, ses horreurs.
Et pourtant,
l’un n’exclut pas l’autre.
L’Art aussi est très fort
à rendre joyeux ;
l’Art a une fonction enthousiasmante.
Il permet de créer.
Il permet de s’exprimer.
Il stimule, il régule, il libère.
Il est un véritable outil de bien-être.
Et dans l’art, il est des formes
qui peuvent particulièrement
rendre heureux.
Et moi, eh bien, j’ai trouvé ma forme,
c’est la danse.
Je n'ai pas fait ce constat en un jour.
La danse m’a fait emprunter
un chemin long et sinueux
avant que je ne me rende compte
qu’elle était ma source de joie.
D’abord, j’ai eu un prix de conservatoire
en danse classique puis j’ai bifurqué.
J'ai fait de longues études
pour devenir notaire.
Comment vous dire ?
C’est comme si j’avais fait
le grand écart, sans échauffement.
Mais après 17 années de notariat,
j'ai bifurqué à nouveau.
Alors, comment j’ai fait
pour tenir autant de temps
dans un métier qui était
loin de mes rêves ?
Eh bien, j’ai dansé
chaque soir, chaque week-end,
pour mieux supporter
ce que je faisais dans la semaine.
Et, j’avoue, j’ai eu beaucoup de chance.
Autour de moi, j’ai toujours eu
une personne pleine d’humour
qui faisait que le rire
compensait les larmes
que j’avais à faire ce que je faisais.
Et puis, le jour où j’ai réussi
à quitter le notariat,
à me libérer de cette obligation,
eh bien je me suis posé
une question plusieurs fois :
« Comment faire pour que chaque matin soit
une fête en sautant dans mes vêtements ? »
Et là, j’ai compris :
il me fallait faire un choix,
celui de reprendre la danse.
Alors, quand on prend
une décision, tout s’organise,
mais le moment de faire
des choix fait peur.
Et j’y suis parvenue,
mais progressivement.
Je suis allée d’expériences positives
en expériences joyeuses,
et de cette manière,
j’ai opéré le retournement,
et je suis devenue
danseuse professionnelle,
pour ma plus grande joie.
Envoyer valser ma carrière de notaire
pour être danseuse
a été un premier pas vers mon
épanouissement personnel, évidemment,
mais il me restait encore
à faire l’ascension vers mon nirvana.
Et j’y suis arrivée.
Oui, oui, j’y suis arrivée !
Alors non, je ne vais pas danser
pour vous aujourd’hui,
vous n’êtes pas là pour ça,
et moi non plus, d’ailleurs.
Non, je vais plutôt vous raconter comment,
en quête de mon bien-être,
avec la danse pour tout bagage,
et la joie fermement accrochée à mon cœur,
eh bien, c’est en procurant
du bonheur aux autres
que je suis parvenue à décrocher la lune.
D’abord, je me suis dit :
« Prends du recul, observe, écoute. »
Je sais d'expérience que ne pas être
écouté peut diriger vers la perte de sens.
Et puis, j’ai beaucoup observé,
et j’ai vu que, sur cette planète,
de nombreuses personnes
se contentent de la personnalité
pour exclure, juger.
Et je me suis dit :
« Mais que de joie sacrifiée !»
Pour ma part, j'ai préféré regarder
d'abord le meilleur en chacun.
Et puis, je me suis mise
à prêter une attention fine
aux masques que nous portons tous
pour protéger nos vulnérabilités.
Et c’est avec ces pensées ainsi guidées
que je peux, avec mes moyens,
chaque jour depuis,
remettre de l’humanité dans ma vie
et dans la vie
des personnes que je côtoie.
Parce qu’il faut dire aussi que
plusieurs questions me taraudent :
« Pourquoi vivre sur cette planète
si c’est pour se priver des joies
et des bonheurs qu’elle nous procure ?
Pourquoi notre passage sur Terre ne serait
pas qualitatif, voire merveilleux ?
Et pourquoi si on parvient à être heureux,
on garde ce bonheur pour soi ? »
Eh bien, mes pensées et ma démarche sont
allées bien au-delà de mon imagination.
Vous allez comprendre.
Si je vous dis :
« Cancer »,
« Peur »,
« Traitement ».
Et maintenant, si je vous dis :
« Joie de vivre »,
« Musique »,
« Danse ».
On voit là qu’on touche
à deux mondes a priori inconciliables.
Pourtant, dans mon quotidien,
c'est ce que je fais.
Je concilie ces deux univers.
Je suis danseuse au chevet des personnes
touchées par le cancer et en fin de vie.
Mon opéra Garnier à moi,
c’est Gustave Roussy,
le Centre européen de Recherche
et de Soins du cancer.
Imaginez,
un couloir d’hôpital,
des portes de chambres fermées,
des brancardiers et des soignants
qui passent et repassent,
et au loin, on entend
une petite musique légère
depuis une sono portative posée
sur un chariot de soins.
Et là, d’un coup, on voit une danseuse.
C’est moi.
Tantôt, je suis habillée en fée,
tantôt en princesse,
tantôt en danseuse indienne,
tantôt en danseuse orientale,
tantôt en ange, je danse.
Je danse entre les chariots,
entre les personnes en visite,
entre les brancards
et les sièges roulants,
et d'un coup, une porte s'ouvre.
Imaginez encore,
tout en dansant, je me faufile
dans l’embrasure de la porte,
et je dis : « Bonjour ! »
La plupart du temps, je ne suis pas
attendue, c’est une surprise.
Mais la curiosité et l’étonnement
vont faire que je suis invitée à entrer,
et je vais entrer
dans l’intimité de la chambre.
Dans un grand élan
de joie et de générosité,
j’improvise entre le mur,
le lit, la chaise, le pied à perfusion,
et je souris sans discontinuer.
Et quand la danse est terminée,
(Clappement des mains)
on applaudit tous avec des sourires
et même parfois des éclats de rire.
Et avant de quitter la chambre,
je prends le temps de l’échange
avec le patient, ses proches.
Je les regarde, je les écoute,
et le cadeau de ma présence,
même passagère, aura offert un voyage,
un voyage riche.
Il y a des pleurs, il y a des rires,
il y a des moments suspendus,
il y a du mouvement, il y a des silences,
il y a des douleurs, il y a de la couleur.
Parfois, il y a une personne
qui se lève et qui vient danser avec moi.
Et parfois, elle est dans le coma ;
alors, je me pose
sur son souffle pour danser.
Et parfois elle est en fin de vie,
et je reste juste là, à ses côtés.
Parfois, il y a des yeux qui se lèvent
au ciel avec des soupirs,
et parfois il y a un sourire
accompagné d’un merci.
Et parfois, il y a une porte qui se ferme.
Parfois, il y a une personne
qui est juste heureuse
d’entendre la musique préférée
de la personne qu’elle chérit.
Et parfois, des soignants
entrent dans la chambre avec moi,
ferment la porte, éteignent la lumière,
et dansent avec moi autour du lit,
comme si on était en boîte de nuit.
Mais il y a surtout des humains,
des humains en quête de sens
sur ce qui leur arrive et sur la vie,
des humains qui sont comme des enfants
à la vue d’une fée ou d’une princesse,
à l’écoute d’une musique qui va bercer
leur cœur, leur corps, leur âme.
Et moi, tant qu’ils sont vivants,
je mets de la vie dans leur vie,
avec un sourire éternellement
accroché à mes oreilles
et la danse pour sublimer les moments.
Alors, chaque semaine, avec les soignants,
nous transformons ainsi les douleurs
des patients et de leurs proches en joie,
et ce qui est incroyable, c’est que
ça me rend immensément heureuse.
Le cercle est vertueux.
Alors, je sais ce qu’on va dire,
et on me le dit souvent.
On plaque beaucoup de théories
sur mes interventions.
On me dit : « C’est de la thérapie. »
Mais je vous le dis, dans ces conditions,
nous sommes tous des thérapeutes.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu’en grec ancien,
« thérapie » signifie « prendre soin ».
Et les patients m’en témoignent.
« Quand vous êtes là,
c’est comme un moment d’éternité.
On oublie les chimio, on oublie
les peurs, on oublie les douleurs. »
Et vous savez quoi ?
Le seul ingrédient de base que j’utilise
pour cette recette miracle,
c’est ma joie de danser.
Et chaque semaine, elle est plus grande,
parce qu’elle se nourrit d’elle-même,
et parce qu’elle se répand.
Alors, si la danse
est mon chemin de résilience,
si c’est ma manière d’enchanter
mon passage sur Terre
par la joie qu’elle me procure et qu’elle
procure aux personnes que je croise,
eh bien, je pense que nous pouvons tous
agir pour une humanité meilleure,
chacun à partir de sa propre vérité,
en se reconnectant à sa joie
et en étant présents
les uns pour les autres.
De la sorte, nous pouvons ensemble
faire de notre voyage sur Terre
un merveilleux voyage.
La vie file entre les doigts
si on n’y prête pas attention.
Il est urgent d'être heureux.
Un jour, un patient m’a dit :
« J’oublierai tout si je guéris,
sauf vous. »
Et vous ?
(Applaudissements)
Présentatrice : Bravo, bravo !
Bravo !